hi there steve kaufman here today i'm
going to answer a question that i get
all the time how many words do we need
to know
and sometimes how many words do we need
to know before we can say we're fluent
how many words do we need to know before
we can say we speak the language
how many words do you learn need to know
before you can move on to another
language
my simple answer to this it's a very
difficult question and i'll explain why
the simple answer is a lot you need a
lot of words
now there are some people who say you
can be fluent with a few hundred words i
don't believe that for a second because
fluent implies communication
communication implies understanding what
the native speaker is saying in english
an educated native speaker knows 50 60
or 70 000 words now they don't use them
all
but
they're going to use a fair number of
them
maybe 10 15 000 words in english
i think to be fluent in english you
should have at least the passive
knowledge of 10 to 15 000 words that
doesn't mean you can use them all and
there is this difference between passive
and active but the passive words are
very important because you have to
understand what people are saying and
you gradually as you
uh get involved in meaningful
conversations with people you start to
activate these words that you know
passively but you do need a lot of words
uh it is sometimes said by the way i
should perhaps first explain that i
apologize a bit for the grainy
appearance of the video i'm in palm
springs
uh i wrenched my back now a couple of
days ago so i can't play golf my wife is
off playing golf otherwise she would
shoot me out in the garden where he got
a clearer picture
but uh i'm at home studying korean and
uh decided to make the video here
um and of course i have other tasks like
doing the laundry clean the dishes i'm
uh the house boy now and my wife is uh
off playing golf but such is life
um tonight she's gonna cook me a nice
meal and we'll be even
um
getting back to this main subject
you need a lot of words
some people say well you know
one thousand or two thousand words
accounts for
uh you know uh 75 80 85 percent of any
given language context
that is true
however it's that remaining 15 20
that usually accounts for the the real
you know specific meaning of the
conversation or of the of the the
subject matter of the context and the
others are the very common words that
always appear uh always appear maybe or
i though you we
uh you know if and uh all these words
very common words that appear frequently
all the time they kind of carry the
conversation but the key words very
often are the less frequent words and
therefore you need to have a lot of
words in order to understand what people
are saying
even if you have a lot of words that is
say
passive vocabulary such as we the way we
count them at link and i have
i'll have a look at it here i have a lot
of passive vocabulary in a number of
languages if you go to my profile at
link you'll see a korean i'm doing right
now i've got 25 000 words that the
system says i know in ukrainian it's 35
000. in russian has 86 000 in check it's
60 000. um portuguese which i've done a
fair amount here at 19 000.
german 20 000 you know romanian 21 000.
um italian 21 000 spanish 18 depends how
much i've done these different languages
that link
what does that mean it means that
uh first of all we count the words at
link in such a way that every form of
the word let me see if i can get back to
this every form of the word
is um is represent is considered a
different word because depending on the
case the tense whatever words change in
different languages
so therefore the ratio between
what we might call word families and
words is going to vary from language to
language it may be that 80 000 words in
russian equates to 20 000 words in
english i just don't know i have seen a
number from paul nation at the
university of new zealand
who said
or somewhere in new zealand who said
that the in english the ratio between
word families and words is 1.6 but i'm
not entirely clear on what a word family
is if we take i don't know act action
acting active
actor
is that a one word family or you know i
don't know
so i don't worry so i guess the other
thing is i just say to myself i need a
lot of words and i don't worry about how
many words i need
i know if i'm reading something if a
word is missing i've got to learn it
um
i might say this is perhaps an extremely
rare word and i won't worry about it but
then i don't deliberately try to learn
the words i simply save them at link
they're now highlighted in yellow if
that word appears again and again in
other texts again highlighted in yellow
i'll eventually get to know if if it
doesn't appear for six months i probably
didn't need that word so i don't worry
about it
um
so the key thing is that the word count
at link therefore
is more of a of a of a milestone it's
telling me when at times i may feel that
i'm not making progress in the language
it's telling me in fact you are because
you have accumulated all these words and
i know from experience when i have a
word count of 20 000 and say korean or
or romanian or some other language
if i find myself in a situation
where i have to speak a lot or i have an
opportunity to speak a lot i'm going to
improve very quickly that's what
happened to me when i was in romania
i i haven't spoken very much korean i'm
going to start speaking again i'm going
to speak with uh
my tutor joo hyun on on saturday
and and quite frankly i still have a lot
of trouble understanding
the bigger problem for me and language
earning is not how many words do i need
to know it's where do i find interesting
content that i like to read and like to
listen to and for korean still that is a
challenge the kim yong-ha series which
i've mentioned before is just that
little bit too difficult
and i understand quite well when he
talks
uh you know about literature but when he
actually reads excerpts from
yukio mishima or whatever i have a lot
of trouble following it and there's a
lot of
more difficult vocabulary in you know
straight from works of literature so
uh to me
i just worry about making sure i expose
myself to a lot of the language
and if i have a high word count that
link it tells me that i have been
exposing myself to a lot of the language
if i had been able to find content in
korean on current events with audio and
text
and a pleasant voice like
who's a
very pleasant person to listen to then
i'd probably have 40 000 words by now
because they would have been more
motivated to a lot to do a lot of that
listening really and that would mean
that i would understand better and when
i speak you'll i'll probably put up a
video at some point of my conversation
with ju hyun and i have trouble
understanding her because i simply
haven't done it very much i haven't
spoken much korean and so you need to
you need to uh to practice speaking but
you have to practice the speaking based
on
an ability to understand and that
ability to understand requires words how
many words exactly
i don't know for sure
i think in english 10 to 15 000 words
is that 25 000 words in korean
is it uh 20 30 000 words in russian or
czech i don't know but my own experience
has been that when i when i run into
trouble in the language
it's because i don't know the words
and you know in my progression you know
at first the language is just so much
noise
and then i'm able to separate out where
words end and the next you know one word
ends and the next word begins and pretty
soon i can identify i know exactly
that's a word i don't know as i'm
listening there's a word i don't know
there's a word i don't know and it's
it's the lack of vocabulary that
prevents me from understanding better
not sorting through the grammatical
structures that does you know a lack of
understanding of the grammar can
sometimes cause confusion but the
biggest thing of all is words so my
advice is don't worry about how many
words do i need to know you'll know when
you're comfortable i know when i'm
comfortable when i can understand
quite well i know when i can't express
myself i know what's missing when i try
to say something and i'm looking for
words and can't find them or can't put
words together properly i know so what
do i do
keep listening and reading and find more
opportunities to speak so that i'm
increasing my
my potential my passive vocabulary all
the time and at the same time working to
activate what i have
through exposing myself to more speaking
opportunities but never
never in the with the idea that somehow
i'm going to be
perfect
and i think this is an important point i
think a lot of people
who have a large vocabulary and who feel
they have difficulty speaking are
inhibited by the fact that they think
they should be better than they are
and there's an expression the perfect is
the enemy of the good
in other words if you build up your
passive vocabulary you expose yourself
to speaking opportunities and you
struggle that's good and if you keep
doing it you'll get better and don't
second-guess yourself or worry about
you know the mistakes you made so it's a
long-winded answer i don't think there's
a clear answer if i were to take a stab
at it i would say in english you need 10
to 15 000 words in order to be
comfortable in different situations and
in inflected languages where words have
many different forms you might triple
that number and that's certainly my
target i feel in korean when i'm at 40
000 words on the link count i'll be
doing fine
and for the time being i there's a lot
of gaps when i listen
okay thank you for listening bye for now